notre monde s'excuse aujourd'hui se
trouve pas sur coup de fil à tort parce
qu'on n'écoute pas ses côtés à passer
non c'est pas ça parce qu'on n'a pas
fait tout ce qu'il était possible de
faire dans le jeu même si étonnant je
sais c'est parti comment on a pu passer
à côté de ça je me demande toujours leur
[ __ ] de venir avec un alien du coup on
a évoqué une nouvelle chèvres et nous
allons découvrir son pouvoir spécial
ensemble up
d'accord ça fait rien nickel ben c'est
peut-être ça le pouvoir ne rien faire
c'est pas mal ok d'accord ok ok pas tout
pardon bah oui ah d'accord ça mais
[ __ ] mais c'est quoi ce pouvoir mont
gao bonnieux mon jeu il pète un câble
[Musique]
c'est quoi ils souffrent label non mais
ça bug trop faut que je fasse je m'en
faut que j'en aie d'ici là as-tu eu je
m'en vais c'est partout vous souvenez
vous par tout hasard non pas de sept
hommes qui dansent là haut up de cette
petite statue est juste là non bah voilà
voilà bah voilà produit par la langue
triste sort ce projet coûte pas le
triste sort devrait bien se passer
ok comme ça c'est parfait oh oui oh non
oui et je savais bien qu'elle servait en
tout cas d'adr fois j'ai récupéré et je
n'ai rien fait voilà j'ai offert au mec
qui faisait son footing qu'il a choisi
une poubelle
j'étais plutôt triste un best of roma
statuette c'est pas moi enfin on the
wind atteint voilà on a gagné les
pouvoirs de la tornade
calme-toi cet ep calme-toi parce
qu'après moi aussi je plains pas et je
fais comment pour avoir le pouvoir de la
de la tornade à six auxquelles je laisse
et vous d'accord et je fais tout et des
balades en même temps mais c'est génial
bonsoir j'ai une chèvre inoffensive
c'est une blague
ac n'a rien fait d'accord je suis monté
sur un skate au pelage pigasse et le
tibia je te casse la cheville un peu
plus ça fait mal non as tu vas où ce qui
est avec moi bon bah tu le prends comme
ça et pas de problème alors on y va
aller accroche toi bien je t'ai dit
accroché [ __ ] est prêt à prendre la
descente
oui un battant mais juste une excuse moi
mais tu me dis si j'étais nerveux
as tu m'aimes bien finalement je savais
bien par contre la baleine qui s'est
accrue s'il te plaît au revoir d'accord
à barbonne noyade t'es où
non monsieur je veux bien de sauver mais
attends mais cette femme est carrément
houphouet a fait semblant d'être morte
mais non voilà vous n'avez pas peur je
pars inoffensive à balen tu vas faire
faire mon plan est finalement c'est
parfait allez tous ses semblables
je vous l attention olala temps mon pc
me péter quoi j'ai le boucler le plus
stylé du monde constitué de 80 % la
population de cette ville
il faisait son footing à pas d'heure il
a trouvé la technique qui me par
mondiaux met la tête dans les mains tu
te papa pièces non aux américains des
pointures les enfants vous risquerez
d'avoir peur
non mais attends la montre
stop ou sa petite ordi ça pour rien
shrek à candyland je trouve que ça sonne
bien alors on va découvrir cette fameuse
map hollande pour le moment on découvre
un merveilleux chargement nous voici à
kenzy landes aussi carrément jolis
escarpins colorés
merci c'est gentil hein le tapis rouge
violet jaune bleu enfin bon bref le
tapis quoi ce gentil ça me fait très
plaisir
aulas a amputé j'avais oublié que shrek
est complètement buggé docteur zone
béryl des retours alors qu'est ce qu'on
en a pas ici et un panneau merci pour
l'indication panos très gentil alors
excusez moi est-ce que je peux passer
pardon pardon pardon si je force le
portail nom assez bon on est passé dit
absolument rien et si on va dedans ça
fait cracher le jeu encore une fois à
non oiseaux et bergues looberghe mon
dieu mon dieu ce sont des insectes dans
la salle tous pourquoi me direz-vous
un succès ce que moi je suis comme vous
je pars avec un bon mois non mais calme
et moins ils auront ce moment ensemble
c'est beau monde mais vous m'avez
tromper mais qu'est ce que tu fais toi
dans un club tchèque
à ces mots cup cake c'est mon pays ici
plus tard vous n'êtes pas originaire de
qom dès l'envoi
ben voilà bah je vais nager dans le
sucre voilà ça me plaît beaucoup aux
mondiaux il ya un allié qui donne ce but
encaissé que sept alliés de quoi hier
qu'un bon gentil je peux lui faire un
câlin coach alors non mais a là aussi un
truc cacher c'est un oeuf géant
j'aime les deux géants et si on part
vraiment à voilà je me dis bah voilà on
est dans le néant
c'est fini pour avoir d'aucun solberg on
va essayer de trouver toutes les
batteries de la traction ou éloignées
nom est pourquoi j attends dans un sac
poubelle je n'en sais rien c'est une
embuscade parfait il fait quoi à lui
évoqué le 40 posé sur son toit tu dis
quoi de sa poule bon il encore plus
posée qu'avant et le problème hop
elle est à nous je veux qu'il soit le
plus beau jour de la vie de gisèle
qu'elle s'amuse comme une folle à es22
comme c'est joli à regarder la valse du
banc
je vais danser avec toi j'ai cassé ton
truc se désole vraiment hockey pardon
bah voilà pour l'instant à quoi et pas
de problème qui vient ou pas non à
celles achetées reconnaît john je vais
juste prendre la batterie on est parti à
les butins mais celle fait c'était
c'était trop tard pour laval se dépenser
tout à l'heure là il s'est finie société
hold up to me sens mal steak mais juste
pour la batterie non tu ne pourras pas
la retenir
elle m'appartient hockey plus que 2
poser ou pas bon ok on va poser encore
plus rien des mondes du respect 1 puis
s'assoit sur moi comme ça nommé aux
batteries aulas attention batteries ba
oui mais j'ai prévenu à toutes les
batteries sont présentes
gisèle oui tu gl vient mon témoin dessus
parfait c'est manger diallo nivea
manuellement non si ce n est rejetée dix
mètres un casque ou six ans bon ok je
disais oh là là voilà me voilà gentlemen
gentlemen gisèle et bien se passer
t'as pas le droit de me guillemin tant
que j'ai pris toutes les batteries t'as
pas le droit c'est quelque chose chez
elle plus tard
bon par contre ça soit gisèle désolé
mais on va t'on ascenseur à lui les
morts attendent l'ascenseur on n'a que
très peu de temps pour rentrer on va
attendre le prochain tour puisqu'elle
passe devraient arriver à peu près
maintenant c'est parti
non trop dissipés non je scelle gisèle
et voilà je sais encore moi qui nous
ramène ça ne peut pas se passer comme ça
gisèle
c'est bon on y est on est prêts on est
bien mais tu vas arrêter dormait un pied
pied à torse pied à tort ce massage
cardiaque
c'est bon tu vis en je sais comment te
réveiller à temps mais tu vas te calmer
toit du dehors
c'est pas toi tu as ton diplôme de
sapeurs-pompiers la bombe ont fait
manuellement puisque le wagon il faut
pas trop de nous ouais on s'éclate 1
c'est cool d'être copain avec super go
out
non non gisèle doit bien chez elle je
suis là tu te casses et de chez elle je
veux tu abandonné gl tu m'excuses armand
jeu peut plus admettre que tu es ma
femme
surtout que tu veux voir uniquement côté
droit de monter sur mon dos et ça moi je
n'accepte pas c'est une rupture
difficile et douloureuse gisèle se
suicide un peu après savez vous voulez
bien des copains son grand frère arrive
il est en route je dirais même mes
grands frères voit la défonce les
défenses le à temps et sous aaa
voilà un qui cache la tête dernière
chance pour est mon ami non tu continue
de parler avec lui d'une baleine alors
là c'est banque de respect je vais me
venger d'un mec tu m'as fait galérer
déjà non on est insensible non il
s'offrit vite course poursuite jusqu'à
la fin des temps ils arriveraient à
s'enfuir à me faire tomber de son bateau
mais je m'en fous parce que je suis une
fille abri qui flotte parce qu'on a
gagné
il ya bien des trois on va gagner et
s'il vous plaît ça y est je suis accro
je suis accro je veux gagner en
souplesse
peu importe que ces mêmes c'est un petit
bonbon n'y a pas de problème c'est vous
qui pas du tout c'est à moi c'est vous
les machines sont truquées là le match
et son truc je m'en vais parce que je
peux vous faire perdre plus de temps à
lâcher des machines sont ok mouillart
voilà à tellement mais une nouvelle
chance de valser avec quelque chose
salut table on va le sang semblent ou
pas non bon je veux bien de moi s'il te
plaît on fait un super duo j'en suis
convaincu non mais pourquoi personne ne
veut de moi je te propose de belles
c'est gratuitement pour toi
voilà une carrière de danseuse anéantie
en enfin dans bach dont j'ai oublié peut
aller embêter montcalm brel à tout va
bien je reconnais et si shrek avait tété
cyclistes
bon déjà son vélo l'aurait embrocher
apparemment mais c'est le massage vidéo
gratuits retient pas de plaintes
seraient cooney aux mondiaux s'il vous
plaît attention attention ça va être
l'accident se bougeait pas madame
bah oui mais voilà à chaque fois je vais
des coups de sonnette et tout est
toujours pareil quoi en voulons nous au
nom hausse est très beau ce qui se passe
là on a finalement réussi à valser
c'est très beau ce qui se passe
[Musique]
eva l'agencé géant fin de cette vidéo
sur youtube et à tort je pense que là
pour le coup on a fait tout ce qui était
possible de faire dans ce jeu j'espère
qu'il vous aura plus c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo ça fait
vraiment plaisir
on refera une vidéo dessus s'il ya
d'autres grosses mises à jour comme par
exemple dans cette carte était sorti
avec on avait découvert un peu tout ce
bordel on se retrouve temenos nouvelle
vidéo j'espère convaincant se passe très
très bien et ça vous fait très très
plaisir
chatter mobile ou si on va valser un peu
voilà maintenant j'ai la bonne grosse
gerbe
[Musique]
et